fiery roadblocks and empty streets in
culiacan the capital city of Mexico's
Sinaloa state
in the early hours of Thursday Mexican
authorities asked residents to stay in
their homes as Security Forces carried
out a special operation to capture the
alleged drug trafficker ovidio Guzman
the son of Joaquin Guzman better known
as El Chapo
when carrying out land reconnaissance in
the northwest of kuliacan military
personnel arrested a video and it was
the result of six months of
reconnaissance in the area of influence
of this criminal group
the arrest of El Chapo's son set off a
wave of violent confrontations on the
streets of culiacan between Mexican
security forces and the Sinaloa cartel
the violence in Sinaloa prompted the
closure of schools businesses and even
the culiacan airport
the airline Aeromexico confirmed that
one of its commercial flights had been
hit by gunfire before takeoff this
amateur video shows the moment
passengers docked for cover
in 2019 Mexican Security Forces detained
ovidio Guzman sparking a similar wave of
violence that ultimately led to an order
for Mexican president Andres Manuel
Lopez obrador to release him
Security Experts however argue that
despite the high-profile nature of the
arrest the long-term impact for the
Sinaloa cartel itself is negligible
what was done with the rest of this
cartoon leader leaves the criminal
apparatus intact this goes beyond the
cartel because the cartel has
accomplices in companies Banks the
government and the military and all of
that remains intact
the capture of obedio Guzman in Sinaloa
comes just days before a scheduled visit
to Mexico by U.S President Joe Biden and
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
for a summit of North American leaders
where they plan to discuss among other
topics multilateral security strategy
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Mexico City